ja und in berlin grüße ich jetzt stephan
mayer sportpolitische sprecher der
unionsfraktion im bundestag hallo also
wir haben es ja gerade gehört jetzt
reden doch alle wieder nur über die
politik wo es eigentlich um sport gehen
sollte was müsste sich denn ändern in
zukunft eventuell die kriterien bei der
vergabe von solchen sportlichen
großereignissen
naja die das ioc hat ja die kriterien
durchaus verändert zum beispiel auch
gesteuert dass ich nicht nur städte
bewerben können sondern auf regionen ich
glaube dass es wichtig ist dass auch vor
allem im demokratischen staat sind
wieder verstärkt anstrengungen
unternommen werden dass sich für
olympische sommer- oder winterspiele zu
bewerben man muss ja eines auch ehrlich
sagen am ende waren ja nur noch zwei
städte im rennen vor sieben jahren als
es darum ging wer die olympischen
winterspiele 2022 austragen darf das war
neben peking die kasachischen stadt
almaty sind uns alle einig dass es
derzeit abstrus wäre in kasachstan
olympischer spiele auszutragen und ich
muss ganz ehrlich sagen mir blutet schon
ein stück weit das herz weil ja es gab
ja auch ganz konkrete bemühungen der
sich münchen für diese olympischen
winterspiele bewirbt leider sind die
entsprechenden bürgerbefragungen im jahr
2013 im november 2013 negativ
ausgegangen ich bin mir nämlich
persönlich sehr sicher dass wir gute
chancen gehabt hätten ich glaube das ioc
hatte sich sehr schwergetan an münchen
vorbei zu gehen also in zukunft dadurch
sollten mehr demokratische staaten
wirklich ernsthafte bemühungen an
stellen sie womöglich spiele zu bewerben
das geht aber nur mit den bürgerinnen
und bürgern und nicht gegenüber und das
ist glaube ich auch ein eine wichtige
schlussfolgerung aus diesen
winterspielen entwickeln aber sie haben
das ja schon angesprochen die realität
sieht eben anders aus man hatte ja im
prinzip nur die wahl zwischen china und
kasachstan
und ich sag mal wie gesagt sie in bayern
muss es wissen wie schwer das ist da
sowas zu organisieren und die menschen
mitzunehmen wir haben jetzt die fußball
spiele dann in katar also es hat sich ja
bis jetzt niemand anderes beworben und
es wird wahrscheinlich immer schwieriger
weil das ja mit sehr viel finanziellen
mitteln verbunden ist solche spiele
solche großereignisse auszurichten was
wäre denn dann wäre der weg aber ich sag
mal aus dieser krise die wir bereits
haben
ich glaube dass dies kein kurzfristiger
prozesses sondern ein mittel und
längerfristige man muss aus meiner sicht
den bürgerinnen und bürgern in
demokratischen ländern es gab ja auch
überlegungen in der schweiz sind in
schweden mit stockholm sich für die
olympischen winterspiele zu bewerben man
muss den bürgern stärker verdeutlichen
dass sie persönlich auch einen mehrwert
ziehen was die verbesserung der
infrastruktur anbelangt aus meiner sicht
müssen olympische spiele auch in zukunft
immer klimaneutrale spiele sein es muss
wenn es um die themen mobilität geht es
logistik natürlich auch auf
nachhaltigkeit wert gelegt werden dürfen
möglichst zu wenig neue flächen
versiegelt werden und es gibt aber
durchaus auch natürlich einen mehrwert
für den breitensport ich bin nach wie
vor der überzeugung dass olympische
spiele wie auch andere sport
großveranstaltungen in besonderer weise
geeignet sind auch einen großteil der
bevölkerung hinter sich zu scharen und
auch zu vereinigen wenn eben deutlich
gemacht wird dass für die bürgerinnen
und bürger mehr davon übrig bleibt als
nur 16 tage sport und 16 tage aufenthalt
von funktionären und von
spitzenpolitikern in der jeweiligen
stadt sondern dass über diese 16 17 tage
hinaus ist einen nachhaltigen mehrwert
gibt für den breitensport für kinder und
jugendsport auch für die verbesserung
der verkehrsinfrastruktur und das muss
ein prozess sein den kommen darf man
auch den bürgern nicht auf optimieren
sondern den muss man mit den bürgerinnen
und bürgern in den jeweiligen staaten
gemeinsam entwickelt halten sie denn
diesen diplomatischen boykott für
richtig lässt man da nicht vielleicht
die sportler ein bisschen allein wäre es
nicht vielleicht besser gewesen
es wäre von offizieller seite jemand mit
gefahren und hätte dann dort direkt vor
ort kritik angebracht
ich persönlich habe es für gut gefunden
wenn ein mitglied der bundesregierung zu
den spielen nach peking fahren würde
die auch andeuten um
ist nicht unbedingt öffentlich aber
zumindest gegenüber den politischen
machthabern in china gegenüber dem
präsidenten shipping auch deutliche
kritik anzubringen was die
menschenrechtssituation anbelangt was
den umgang mit minderheiten mit den
uiguren anbelangt das verhältnis und die
vorgehensweise gegenüber teil waren
gegenüber anfang an betrifft dort wäre
natürlich ein sport- großereignisse wie
olympische winterspiele eine aus meiner
sicht sehr gut geeignete plattform um
insbesondere auch informelle gespräche
zu führen deswegen glaube ich und ich
glück diese auch gewinner des spiegels
von den athletinnen athleten wäre es
durchaus wünschenswert gewesen muss man
jetzt mittlerweile sagen wenn deutsche
spitzenpolitiker insbesondere auch
vertreter der bundesregierung nach
peking wieder reißen würden
beziehungsweise gereist wir ja vielen
dank ihnen stephan mayer war das
sportpolitische sprecher der
unionsfraktion im bundestag dankeschön
nach berlin wie schön alles gute